-I'm gonna ask you
for some silly words,
nouns, verbs, adjectives,
et cetera.
As we do that, they'll
be written onto cue cards, okay?
And then we'll act out
a dramatic Mad Libs scene
right here, live,
in front of our audience.
You ready for this?
-All right.
-All right, here we go.
Very good.
All right,
now we need some words.
Give me a number.
-6,000.
[ Light laughter ]
-Give me a male name.
-Um...
Donald.
[ Laughter ]
-Give me a pet name
for a rabbit.
-Fuzzy.
-Aww.
An adjective.
-Stinky.
-What you'd shout
if your dentist told you,
"You have six cavities."
-"I hate candy!"
[ Laughter ]
-"I hate candy"?
-Like, "I didn't do it."
-I know.
"How is this possible?" yeah.
-It's not my fault.
-Amount of time.
-17 weeks.
[ Laughter ]
-What a bar--
What a bartender would say
to customers
when the bar's closing.
-Last call?
-Yeah.
-Is that really boring?
-No, it's just very accurate.
[ Laughter ]
Historical event.
-The Revolutionary War.
[ Light laughter ]
-Adjective to describe a fish.
-Slimy.
-Body part.
-Oh. Knees.
[ Light laughter ]
Keep it clean.
-Plural occupations.
-Scuba divers.
-Somebody said "yes"
in the audience.
[ Laughter ]
"Yes! Finally."
Plural animals.
-Llamas.
Verb ending in I-N-G.
-Um...ghosting.
[ Laughter ]
-Celebrity name.
-Kim Kardashian.
-Plural type of food.
-Bananas.
-Character from "Friends."
-Rachel.
[ Cheers ]
-Insult a kid would say.
-You couldn't
carry a blank strap.
[ Laughter ]
Is that right?
Is that what it is?
♪♪
[ Laughing ]
-Gosh.
That is the perfect answer.
[ Laughter ]
"You couldn't carry
a blank strap."
-Is that --
Is that what it is?
I didn't really get it.
-Something like that, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Another insult a kid would say.
Another one.
-You suck at "Fortnite"!
[ Laughter ]
-One more insult a kid
would say, then I'm done.
-Um...
You look like a Cheeto.
[ Laughter ]
I have like one sigh with that.
-Yes, I hear you.
I hear you.
-Okay.
-Plural object.
-Um...chairs.
-Verb.
-Um...
Um...
Flush.
-A body -- Another body part.
-Uh, butt.
[ Laughter ]
-Another verb.
-Um...
Fart.
I do this with my son a lot,
so I, like, kind of have
set answers.
-Cartoon character.
-Mickey Mouse.
-One more.
Last verb ending in I-N-G.
-Sniffing.
[ Laughter ]
-There you go, right there.
Okay, we have filled out
all the words for our scene.
Are you ready to perform it?
-So excited.
-All right, here we go.
-All right.
-Let's do this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Birds chirping ]
[ Laughter ]
Really is --
Really is a beautiful
day to go apple picking.
This is the most fun
I've had in 6,000 years.
[ Laughter ]
-Listen, Donald, I've been
thinking, and we need to talk.
-What is it, Fuzzy?
[ Laughter ]
-What I'm about to say
might be stinky to hear,
but here it goes.
I think we should break up.
-I hate candy!
[ Laughter ]
-I'm so sorry.
We've shared so much
over the past 17 weeks, but...
[ Laughter ]
...last call.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's cold.
How long have you've
been feeling this way?
-Since the Revolutionary War.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I can't believe this.
Is this because
of my slimy knees?
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, it's not.
We're just -- We're just
really different people.
I was brought up
by two scuba divers.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And you were raised by llamas.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I enjoy --
I enjoy going out,
and come home every night to
find you ghosting on the couch,
watching YouTube videos of
Kim Kardashian eating bananas.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-I understand.
Well, I have something
to tell you, too,
that's not easy to admit.
I've been cheating on you
with Rachel from "Friends."
[ Laughter ]
-You couldn't
carry a blank strap!
[ Laughter ]
-You --
You suck at "Fortnite"!
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you cook --
you look like a Cheeto!
[ Laughter ]
-Hey!
-I'm taking the chairs
and moving out.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey!
Hey, please --
please don't flush.
[ Light laughter ]
That's a term that my llama
parents used to say.
[ Laughter ]
I hate seeing you do that,
so just have a seat here.
I'm sorry
things didn't work out.
-I am, too.
I'll --
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
I'll always --
[ Both laugh ]
I'll always have a special
place for you in my butt.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
[ Laughter continues ]
-It's during --
[ Laughter ]
It's during times like this,
I like for us to recite
our favorite love quote.
-"You got to fart
like Mickey Mouse is watching."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
"And you got to love
like there's nobody sniffing."
And scene!
-There you go.
Thank you.
My thanks to Natalie Portman!